problem number 600 let's do the skinny I
want to use this tool problem number six
have to restart my computer so
everything got reset okay if m and K are
positive and all right now yes something
looks fairly complicated and they say
that 10 10 m squared K to the negative 1
is equal to 100 m what is m to the
negative 1 in terms terms of K so let's
see if we can simplify that thing I
wrote at the top k to the negative 1 is
equal to 100 m well what happens if you
divide well let's divide both sides by
10 so you get M Squared k to the
negative 1 that's the same thing as M
squared over k is equal to mu divided
the other side by 10 is equal to 10 m
let's divide both sides by M and they're
positive so we can do that so it's not 0
so you get em over k is equal to 10
right because M squared divided by M is
just 10 and so you could say that if we
want to we could say that well let's
just sit m is equal to 10 k right but
they want they don't want to figure out
what M is in terms of K they want to
know em the negative 1 well m to the
negative 1 is just 1 over m so if we
just invert both sides of this we know
that 1 over m is equal to 1 over 10k and
that's the same thing of course as m to
the negative 1 and 1 over 10k that's
choice D problem number 7 we are on
problem number 7 and I will do in move
Edna and Nancy leave the house for a
common friend at the same time and walk
for four hours four hours is how far
they walk Edna walks due east at the
average rate of four kilometers per hour
so Edna walks that's West
Edna walks east at 4 km/h 84 Nancy walks
due north at an average of three
kilometers per hour so Nancy is going to
walk north and for Nancy I guess an end
for north and north at 3 km/h 3 km/h I'm
doing this a little bit messy be at the
point Nancy's going north Edna's going
east what is the straight line distance
between them in kilometers at the end of
four hours at the end of four hours so
let's just this is Pythagorean theorem
at the end of four hours how far has
Edna traveled east they're starting at
the same point I when I don't liked it
uses slightly thicker how far as Edna
gone East well she's going to be going
for km/h she's going to be going for
km/h times four hours that equals 16
kilometers right that's how far Edna
went east now how far did did Nancy go
north well she went at oh my god i was
using the line tool undo she went north
so same thing she went north at so 3
km/h right that's when I said yeah 3
kilometers per hour times four hours so
she what traveled to 12 kilometers this
is a pythagorean theorem problem they
want it so the after four hours Nancy's
there Edna's there and you just need to
figure out the straight line distance
between them we just have to figure out
this and actually a trick to this I mean
you could you know you could just say
let's say that we want to solve for x
right you could say that x squared is
equal to 12 squared plus 16 squared and
you could you know figure it out or you
could make the further realization that
that this is essentially a 345 trying
right you could say that well this is
four times for this is three times four
so this side is going to be five times
for right if you remember your 3 4 5
triangle Pythagorean theorem if you
don't just do this you get x squared is
equal to 144 plus 256 so x squared is
equal to 400 and then you get x is equal
to 20 so either way you could do it
either way this would have been a little
bit less math so x is equal to 20 so it
is choice e all right i'm gonna show at
east to the other one walks north right
this choice e all right problem number 5
oh sorry problem number 8 this is
actually i'm using an old workbook that
was done used by my cousin when she was
in seventh grade she's now in 10th grade
and she's marked up some of these
problems i have a little bit trouble
reading and not not she was only in 7th
grade but some of the problems are
circled to correct so that's what's
making me second-guess myself every now
and then but anyway back to the problems
she now doesn't get any problems
incorrect but back to the problem all
right figure above shows she's actually
the reason why I started doing this
because I have worked with her and she
saw improvement and then I worked with
her brother and they saw improvement I
said well let me just make a bunch of
videos so a bunch of people can can see
some improvement so let's see what they
have drawn here for problem number 8 let
me draw the x-axis draw the y axis and
then they drew a parabola the figure
above shows the graph of a quadratic
function that has a minimum at point 1 1
it's at the point 1 comma 1 it has its
minimum point do that in different color
it's a minimum point there if f of b is
equal to f of 3 which of the following
could be the value of B so on the graph
they drew if you go to three one two
three and if you just follow up see
you going to one two three four five so
you go up five so one two three four
five it's like a point here all right
and at least this side of the parabola
or the quadratic goes something like
this for everyone is carefully as
possible right and the other side is
symmetric right it does it'll do the
same thing it'll it'll go right and then
once they say f of b is equal to f of 3
so f of 3 is here and you know if you
want to get the exact number it's like f
of 3 is equal to 5 that actually doesn't
even matter because this is one right
because this is the point 11 this is the
point this is X is equal to 3 and the
big realization is as well this is a
quadratic this is a parabola this is its
minimum point so it's going to be
symmetric around this point right so if
it reaches if it reaches five here so it
took two units to reach to reach five
going to the right to going in the
positive x direction so similarly it's
going to take two units to reach five
going in the negative x direction right
so what's two units less than 1 so 1 2
you'd get to negative one so at be could
be equal to negative 1 actually be would
be equal to negative 1 so the correct
answer is C the choice is B is equal to
negative 1 let's see if I can squeeze in
problem number 9 problem number oops
problem number 9 a family of five is
planning a four-day camping trip each so
five people times four days each person
will need one bottle of water for each
day of the trip so x 1 bottle right per
day per person if water is sold only in
three bottle packages how many packages
must the family by for the trip well how
much water do they need eat there's five
people for days and the east
bottle of water a day so they need 20
bottles right they need 20 bottles and
it only comes in packages of three or
multiples of three so they could if they
bought six packages would be 18 bottles
essen enough so they have to get seven
packages seven packages x 3 is equal to
21 bottles so they have to buy seven
packages not too bad huh all right I'll
do the next problem in the next video
I'll see you soon